Prof: Okay.
Population growth is one of
those things in ecology that is
good to get kind of an intuitive
feeling about.
And the main thing that you
need to grasp about population
growth is that it is
multiplicative.
So that if you have a certain
number of things,
and they are making more
things, then the amount you have
next time is proportional to the
number you have this time,
and it multiplies by itself.
It turns out that this kind of
process takes a little bit of
playing around with to
internalize.
What we'll do today is start by
talking about density
independent growth,
and that is basically compound
interest.
So compound interest yields
exponential growth,
and if it only went on forever,
we would all be very wealthy.
When I was a professor in
Switzerland,
at one point I suggested to the
Swiss that if they had simply
invested 100 Swiss francs,
when the university was founded
in 1460,
that they would have an
endowment greater than the gross
domestic product of the planet,
at this point;
at only a nice conservative
Swiss 4% interest.
And they would,
but they looked at me knowingly
and they said,
"Ah, you've forgotten
Napoleon"
who wiped them out.
> Okay?
So the basic point about--let's
see, have I gotten through that?
Yes--the basic point that I
want you to get about compound
interest is that it will very
rapidly produce a whole lot of
stuff,
and that the rate of
multiplication is quite a bit
faster than the arithmetic
difference in the interest rate.
The idea of this whole chart is
to show you that a small
difference in interest rate can
make a huge difference in the
outcome.
So I've used basically a bank
account to attract your
interest, with dollars,
but this will work with
organisms and populations just
as well.
The time to double for money
invested at 1% is 70 years;
5% is 14 years;
and 10% is 7 years.
And the yield after 70 years,
on $100.00, looks like this.
You get $200.00 at 1% interest,
and you get $100,000.00 at 10%
interest.
Okay?
So a ten times increase in the
interest rate leads to a 512
times increase in the outcome.
Small differences in interest
rates make big differences in
outcomes.
And as we'll see in a sec,
the interest rate on a
population is the difference
between the birth and the death
rate.
So you can jiggle the birthrate
a little bit,
you can jiggle the death rate a
little bit,
you'll get a fairly substantial
difference in the growth rate,
the interest rate on the
population,
and something like this can
happen.
So I want to take you just
through the math of doubling
time, so you understand that
previous chart.
And you also need to start
getting familiar with this kind
of notation, because in
population dynamics and ecology
it is used pervasively.
So B is often used for the
birthrate, D for the death rate,
and the per capita growth rate
is the birthrate minus the death
rate.
Okay?
That's birthrate per capita,
death rate per capita,
and this is growth rate per
capita.
So if you've got N organisms,
then you have the simplest
differential equation you can
write down practically,
which is that the rate of
change of the population is
equal to the growth rate,
times the number of organisms
that are present.
Okay?
That means that the slope of
population growth is RN.
So if we have N on the y-axis,
and time on the x-axis,
it looks something like this.
And I put this in to indicate
that for a given change in time
unit,
the amount of growth you get in
the population just keeps on
going up and up and up.
Okay?
It keeps jumping.
So that the rate of increase in
an exponential process is
proportional to the growth rate
times the amount of stuff that's
there;
and that's the slope of the
relationship.
So if you write this down and
rearrange it a little bit,
then you can integrate both
sides, and you get that the
natural log of the number of
organisms in the population is
equal to the growth rate times
the amount of time that's
elapsed since they started
growing,
plus some constant.
You can exponentiate both sides.
So if you raise E to the log,
you get N.
Okay?
And rearrange to get that.
So the number of organisms you
have T-time units later,
is equal to the number that you
started with,
times E, the base of the
natural logarithms,
raised to R times T.
And, in fact,
that's the basic compound
interest formula as well.
So you can use that for bank
accounts, just as well as you
can use it for organisms.
So you ask yourself,
"Well how long does it
take for that population to
double?"
Where did I come up with that
chart that I showed you on the
second slide?
Well the doubling time is the
time that it takes for whatever
that number is,
divided by what you started
with, to equal 2.
And that will happen when 2 =
e^(RT.
)So the log of 2 is equal to R,
times the doubling time;
and the doubling time is about
0.69 divided by R,
because that's the log of 2.
So you can multiply that by
100, if you want to use percent,
and you get the simple rule of
thumb that you can divide 69 by
the interest rate to get the
doubling time.
Or, as a rule of thumb,
if you're comfortable with
approximations,
it's a little easier to divide
72 by the interest rate to get
the doubling time,
because you can divide 72 by 3
and by 4 and by 8,
and things like that.
Okay?
Now, I'd like you to get a
little bit familiar with this
sort of thing.
And here is a voluntary
homework assignment.
Some of you will enjoy this,
some of you will not.
This can easily be done on a
spreadsheet.
You will have to look up a few
numbers on the Web;
they are readily available.
I'd like you to consider an
asexual rabbit population
consisting only of females,
and each individual reproduces
at an age of just three months;
gives birth to two offspring
and dies.
I did that, I set it up that
way so that you would have a
doubling every three months.
All of the offspring survive to
reproduce;
that preserves the doubling.
You can play around with these
assumptions.
Adult rabbits weigh one kilo.
There's no density dependence.
I didn't give you this,
but let's say they cover 100
square centimeters,
something like that;
so about 1/10^(th) of a meter.
How long will it take to cover
Science Hill two meters deep in
rabbits?
I think you'll be surprised,
it doesn't take very long.
We can just start with one,
and you're going to have
Science Hill six feet deep in
rabbits pretty quick.
But you can go farther than
that.
Okay?
How long will it take for the
leading edge of the expanding
ball of fur to exceed the speed
of light,
and what will be the diameter
of the ball at that point,
measured in earth orbits?
I think the answer is roughly
750 years, and you're somewhere
about the diameter of Jupiter.
Okay?
About; if I recall correctly.
I did this once.
And then you can ask how long
will it take to reach the point
of gravitational collapse into a
black hole?
Well actually I think it will
happen before the ball of fur
hits the speed of light.
Okay?
Because you're well out beyond
the diameter of the sun.
The point of this ridiculous
example is exponential growth
rapidly makes a heck of a lot of
stuff.
Okay?
I have left unexplained where
the rabbits got their food.
>
Okay?
So a small change in growth
rate will make a big difference
in the outcome.
Remember how to integrate this
differential equation;
it's pretty straightforward.
Doubling times are a very
convenient way to conceptualize
growth rates.
So you can divide 69 by the
growth rate to get the doubling
time;
divide it by the growth rate in
percent to get the doubling
time, for any process.
Now in summarizing this,
there was no age structure.
All of those numbers that we
were counting up represented the
population as though every
single organism in it had the
same probability of reproducing
or dying;
and that's not true.
One of the most obvious things
about populations is that
organisms of different ages
reproduce at different rates and
have different risks of dying.
So it would be nice to be able
to do population dynamics,
with a bit more realism,
by sticking in all the
difference that age structure
makes;
in other words,
doing demography.
Pre-adult organisms don't give
birth.
Old organisms have high
probabilities of dying.
Sometimes newborn have very
high probabilities of dying.
And if we look around the
world, we can see that there are
roughly speaking three different
kinds of survivorship curves.
We have age on the x-axis here,
in an arithmetic scale,
and we have survivorship on the
y-axis, in a logarithmic scale.
So when you see something like
a type-3 survival curve,
that is a huge drop in the
number that are present say,
that are all born here,
at age 0.
And on this scale there's only
one of them left alive after a
short period of time.
Here you have a straight line,
and if you have a semi-log
graph,
and you have a straight line,
what the straight line means is
that a constant proportion are
dying at a given time interval.
So if you are looking say at
this point,
on the type-2 survival curve,
you have 1/10^(th) of what you
had at the start,
and if you look at this point
on the type-2 survival curve,
you have 1/10^(th) of what you
had there.
So the straight line is a
constant proportion dying in
each time interval.
And up here,
life looks pretty good,
until you get to be a somewhat
aged adult, and then you have
rapid aging.
So the kinds of things that
have type-1 survival curves are
humans, elephants and
albatrosses.
Small birds have type-2
survival curves,
as do hydra.
And oysters and trees have
type-3 survival curves;
and orchids.
They make hundreds of millions,
or billions of seeds;
most of the seeds die;
and once you have made it to
adulthood, then your prospects
are pretty good.
This curve is pretty flat here.
It's almost like this curve is
up here.
So when we look around the
world, we see that different
kinds of organisms have a--
well they actually have quite a
bit of continuous variation in
demography,
but if we want to stick them
into categories,
we can see some illustrative
extreme cases,
that help us to understand the
diversity of population dynamics
that organisms encounter,
as well as the diversity of
selection pressures that they
encounter.
Now in order to analyze that,
we need a bit of demographic
notation.
And I'll step through this,
just pointing out some of the
key things where people can
stumble when they first
encounter this notation,
and points that you want to
make sure you keep in your
memory as important
distinctions.
The first one is the
distinction between age and
time,
and that is the distinction
between being 62-years-old and
21-years-old in 2009,
and what's happened over the
last 20 years.
Okay?
So you can have people of
different ages at the same time,
and you can have people of the
same age at different times.
So X keeps track of age and T
keeps track of time.
Then there are two different
kinds of ways of thinking about
survival.
One is the probability of
surviving from now to next year,
or now to the next time unit,
however you choose to scale
your time unit.
And the other is the
probability of surviving from
birth until now,
which would be the probability
here,
LX, probability of surviving
from birth to beginning of age
class X,
whatever X is.
And that is just the product of
all of the PXs up to that point.
So it's the product of
surviving from birth to age 1;
age 1 to age 2;
age 2 to age 3;
etcetera, up to now.
Then once you get to be X years
old, MX is the symbol that keeps
track of how many babies a
female would have,
that survived to that age.
Alpha is age at maturity;
Omega is age at last
reproduction.
And age at maturity doesn't
mean, in demography,
age at acquisition of secondary
sexual characteristics or
acquisition of the ability to
reproduce,
it means the actual age at
which a baby arrives;
okay, when offspring are born.
Little-r is the population
growth rate.
And here we have a collection
of three different growth rates,
and they mean somewhat
different things.
And if you're thinking about
zero population growth,
the value of these things is
going to be different for zero
population growth.
r, as I mentioned before,
is B minus D,
birthrate minus death rate,
and it's an instantaneous per
capita population growth rate.
Okay?
So it is comparable say to the
interest rate that your bank
tells you that you're getting on
your savings,
or that you're being charged on
your credit card.
Big Ro is the lifetime
expectation of female offspring.
In demography we tend to keep
track only of females,
because they are the
rate-limiting sex.
They are normally,
as you remember from sexual
selection lectures,
the limiting resource,
and it is their reproductive
rate that actually determines
the rate at which the population
will grow.
So this is the rate of growth
per generation,
and it's Ro;
and Lambda, which is e^(r) is
the multiplicative rate of
growth per time unit.
And you'll see how these
numbers compare as we go through
the next slides.
These things are calculated on
the basis of life tables.
So a life table is an
accounting tool,
and frankly life tables are a
bit like natural selection in
the following way;
they actually do imply a kind
of natural selection,
but that's not the point I want
to emphasize.
They are deceptively simple.
Life tables are basically a
rather boring kind of accounting
of births and deaths,
but they have very deep
implications.
Just as natural selection is
based on four very simple
conditions that you can write
down,
but nevertheless creates all of
the complexity of brains and
livers and everything else,
life tables have that kind of
deceptive simplicity.
So LX--we're going to make a
simple one--LX is the
probability of surviving from
birth to age X.
BX or MX is the number of
female offspring,
born to females of age X.
And LXMX is the probability
both of surviving to X and of
having MX offspring.
So the sum, LXMX,
over all ages X,
is the expected number of
female offspring per female per
lifetime;
that's R0.
So you can just put an equals
sign in here,
that's R0.
Okay?
So that's a measure of
population growth,
an important one.
And if we take a simple example
where we have this survival rate
from one year to the next--
and I've set this equal to 0,
so that nobody makes it to age
3--
starting at birth
everybody--we're keeping track
of things that get born--
so everybody has a probability
of 1 of being born--
because those are the only ones
we're counting--
and 50% of making it to age 1,
and 25% of making it to age 2.
Just P0 times P1 gives us .25
here.
This is the birthrate.
Okay?
So these organisms mature at
age 1 and they get better at
reproducing;
perhaps they continue to grow
and they have 2.4 offspring per
female at age 2.
And these are their
contributions to fitness:
.5 here;
so half of them make it to age
1 and have 1 offspring,
and a quarter of them make it
to age 2 and have 2.4 offspring.
We multiply those numbers
together, sum them up,
we get R0 = 1.10.
The important thing about R0 is
that it's greater than 1.
This population is growing.
Okay?
Now if we want to look ahead
and ask what's going to be the
age distribution in future
years?
If you have a life table for
humans--
you might be interested in
knowing will there be enough
people around,
who are young,
to pay for your Social Security
when you're old?--
you can use this procedure to
do so,
and that's what demographers do
with it.
Okay?
So the number of newborn is the
sum across age classes;
so the number of females alive
that year, times their expected
fecundity.
That's pretty straightforward.
Just take the number of
females, take the average number
of babies they'll have,
and that's the number of
newborn.
The number alive in any older
age class is the number that
were alive in the younger age
class in the previous year,
times the probability they
survived.
That's pretty straightforward.
This is the deceptive
simplicity of life tables;
just straightforward accounting.
So here we have again a
….
this is the same life table we
had before.
Now I've put in 10 organisms in
each of the three age classes.
Okay, we have 10 newborn,
10 1-year-olds,
and 10 2-year-olds.
And this is how the population
will develop.
Half of these survive,
half of these survive.
I've rounded these off to get
whole organisms.
So that's the survival part of
it.
How about the births?
Well these 10 here are going to
be giving birth to 5 offspring,
and these 10 here are going to
be giving birth--
excuse me, these 10 here are
going to be giving,
each of these are going to be
giving birth to 1 offspring.
So that's 10.
And these 10 here give birth to
2.4.
That adds up to 34.
Okay?
This times this,
plus this times this,
is that.
Five offspring come from this
group and 12 offspring come from
this group, and we get 17.
Okay?
And that just keeps going.
So in each generation you can
carry that out as a matrix
transformation.
It's called the Leslie matrix.
You can use all of the
properties of linear algebra to
project things into the future.
You can use mathematics
packages, like MatLab or
Mathematica, and even Excel
spreadsheets,
to carry this process out.
Now if you study that process,
it turns out these are its
critical take-home messages.
Any such process,
where you have a constant rate
of birth and death,
will produce a population that
attains a stable age
distribution in which the
proportion of individuals in
each class remains constant.
So that means like the ratio of
five-year-olds to ten-year-olds
remains constant.
And it will get there fairly
quickly;
not immediately but fairly
quickly.
When it gets into stable age
distribution,
both the entire population and
each age class in it are growing
exponentially at the constant
rate,
r, and that r has exactly the
same meaning as it did when we
were back dealing with a simple
population in just that simple
differential equation.
Okay, so that's this state.
The growth rate of the
age-structured population is the
same as the growth rate of a
density independent population.
So, let's do an example.
Here's a life table that
actually is roughly that of a
small bird.
So the guys that fly into my
bird feeder in Hamden,
the house sparrows,
the chickadees and so forth,
they could have a life table
that looks something like this.
They don't live very long.
So here are the probabilities
of surviving to age 1,2 and 3.
Here are the birthrates.
I've set them constant for the
three age classes.
Here's LXMX.
This is our population growth
rate.
It's 1.2 per generation.
So just based on this,
we can make several interesting
statements.
Their population is growing.
Okay?
And that's because 1.2 is
greater than 1.0.
And it is multiplying actually
1.2 times per generation;
not per year,
but per generation.
We can calculate the generation
time with this formula.
So we just divide sum of LXMX
times X, by R0.
That turns out to be 1.67 years.
And the meaning in words of
generation time,
in demography--it's a technical
meaning--is the average age of
the mother of a newborn.
So that's the average age of
The little-r,
can be estimated--and this is
an estimate, it's not
precise--by taking the log of
big-R and dividing it by the
generation time;
and that's about 0.11.
So this population is growing
at a compound interest rate of
about 11% per year,
and we can use that to go back
and use our doubling time
calculations to figure out,
oh, it's doubling about every
6.3 years.
If I'm putting the bird seed
out there in Hamden,
I had better be ready for large
expenditures.
And I'd like you to note that
R0 is calculated on a different
time period, generation time,
than little-r.
So when big-R0 is equal to 1,
little-r is equal to 0,
and the population is then--the
word is used,
stationary;
it's just replacing itself.
A stationary population is
replacing itself,
but a population with age
structure, that is growing,
can be in stable age
distribution.
Stable age distribution refers
to the ratios between the age
classes;
stationary refers to whether or
not it's just replacing itself,
or whether it's growing or
declining.
Okay?
So that's a rough sketch of
simple demography,
and an introduction to the
different ways that ecologists
and demographers conceptualize
growth rates.
Now I want to criticize--not
really criticize,
but comment on one of the basic
assumptions of this.
The first way that you can
complicate simple dynamics is by
putting in age structure,
but the second way you can
complicate it is by putting in
density.
Here is growth of a bird that
was introduced to Great Britain,
the turtledove,
and it took off from a very
small population,
and it grew exponentially.
Remember, if you have a
straight line on a semi-log
plot--so y-axis here;
numbers is on a log scale;
x-axis is on an arithmetic
scale.
So this is a straight line,
and it's going like
gangbusters, it's growing
exponentially.
And about every,
let's see, one,
two, three--it's increasing in
size about ten times every three
years.
So these doves are really
pumping out the babies and
they're surviving pretty well.
But something happens up here.
This is a real point here;
this is a real point here,
and it starts to level off.
So the question is,
what does increasing population
density do to the demography,
the birth probabilities,
and the death probabilities of
individuals?
Can we understand that in terms
of the kinds of concepts we're
already covered this morning?
Well you've seen this plot
before.
So as density--we can think of
this being a high density
population and this being a low
density population,
with rapid growth,
rapid individual growth--
now not population growth,
but rapid individual growth,
increase of size with age at
low density,
and slow individual growth at
high density.
And I think by now you're
familiar with the idea that
there is a reaction norm for age
and size at maturity.
And if you move from low
density to high density,
basically what happens,
in many cases,
is you get organisms that
mature later,
at a smaller size.
So one of the very basic
characteristics that determines
population growth is age at
maturity.
That's basically the interval
over which the compound interest
is being calculated,
and that's responding
plastically to density.
So as the density of the
population goes up,
the organisms delay maturity,
they mature later--
here, rather than here--and
they mature smaller--
here, rather than here.
So they are less capable of
making babies,
and they're doing so later in
life and at a slower rate.
The other dramatic thing that
happens with density is that
mortality increases.
Here is an experiment that was
done with trout.
This is a log scale here and a
log scale here,
and the flat line here
basically indicates that growth
has stopped,
or that density has stopped
increasing.
And if you just take an
experimental stream bed,
and you seed it with baby
trout, and you do that a number
of times,
at different initial densities
per square meter--
okay?
So this would be 10 raised to
the 2.5 per square meter.
So this is about 300 trout per
square meter,
and this is 10 trout per square
meter over here.
So in arithmetic terms,
we're going from 10 per square
meter,
up to about 300,
and what we get out,
at the end of the experiment,
is roughly 10 per square meter.
So there's an enormous amount
of mortality which is going on,
over on this end.
And you can think of that as
sort of runt of the litter kinds
of things,
baby pigs competing in a
litter, or you can think of it
simply as interspecific
competition.
These trout are competing for
food, and the ones that are best
at finding it are going to be
the ones that survive.
There've been lots of
experiments done with plants.
Here again we have a log scale
on this axis and a log scale on
this axis, and this is the
density of surviving plants
here.
Okay?
So this is the number per
square meter.
On this axis we have the number
that were planted,
and that's going to range
from--down here we're probably
at about 12 or 15,
up to about 1000 per square
meter, were planted.
And these different lines here
are showing you what the density
of plants is 22 days after
planting,
39 days after planting,
61 days after planting,
and 93 days after planting.
And this is the demographic
process that basically leads to
constant final biomass.
So if you go on,
all the way through to harvest,
you're going to end up with
about 100 plants per square
meter,
and the--by the way,
the way that plants regulate
their individual growth,
you essentially get the same
amount of leaf area or root area
covering a square centimeter of
ground.
So if you plant a lot,
you're going to end up with
fewer leaves and less roots,
and you're going to get smaller
plants,
but the total amount of plant
material sitting on that square
meter will be roughly constant,
irrespective of initial
planting density,
if you just let this process go
on long enough.
The other thing that happens is
that as density goes up,
fecundity goes down,
and that's because as density
goes up,
competition for food increases,
individuals are not getting fed
as much,
and they are therefore less
able to make babies.
In this panel over here,
we see basically natural
variation in song sparrows on
Mandarte Island,
which is a small island off the
coast of Vancouver Island;
it's not too far from Victoria.
If you take the ferry from
Vancouver, over to Victoria,
you go within about a kilometer
of Mandarte Island.
Okay?
And this is the number of young
that females were able to
fledge.
These are the years.
So that's 1980,1981, 1982.
This is the number of breeding
females on the island.
And what you see is that as the
number of breeding females
increases, the number they are
able to fledge starts to
decrease.
And in the year 1985 they did
an experiment where they added
food--
so they wanted to see whether
this natural variation could be
manipulated,
just by putting food out on the
island--
and those who were fed were
able to rear nearly four
offspring;
and at high density,
up here, in 1985,
those who were not fed were
only able to rear one.
So there was a difference per
female of nearly three
offspring,
and that was what the
population density was doing to
them,
and the manipulation experiment
showed that it was the density
and that food was the mechanism.
If you look at a dune plant in
the Netherlands--
this is Vulpia,
which is a grass,
and this is growing near
Leiden, on the dunes on the
North Sea in the Netherlands.
The number of seeds per plant,
number of flowing plants per
quarter square meter;
the number goes down.
So the more crowded they get,
the fewer seeds they can make.
So this is variation that's
really going on in Nature,
and it shows you that the
effects of density are quite
real, they're pretty dramatic.
These effects can be combined.
So if we want to combine number
of births and numbers dying,
this would be density,
over here, going from 0 up to a
number K.
The numbers dying increase as
we go across this,
and the numbers being born
decrease,
and at some intermediate point
you have the greatest difference
between the births and the
deaths,
and that difference between
births and deaths is the
recruitment.
Okay?
So the recruitment inferred
from this graph looks like this,
and at 0--you get zero
recruitment when you hit this
number K;
and that number K is called
carrying capacity.
So the population,
under density-dependent
regulation, will increase until
it hits carrying capacity,
and then it will stop growing.
Now as density is taking its
effect, the size distribution of
individuals in the population
often shifts.
So what I'm basically doing
here is I'm showing you all the
things that density does to the
individual lives of the
organisms that are experiencing
this density increase.
And this is a very interesting
one, because basically what's
going on here--and this is
measured in flax.
If you start at low,
medium or high density,
two weeks after emergence the
distribution of body sizes in
the population is pretty
similar;
it's a nice bell-shaped curve.
This is now six weeks from
emergence.
So a bunch of other replicates
have now been gathered.
And you can look at plant
weight here, you can see that
they're bigger,
the scales are changing.
But you'll notice that at the
medium and at the high-density
treatments you're starting to
get quite a bit of skew.
You're starting to get a few
big ones and lots of little
ones;
that's what this kind of
histogram means here,
lots of little ones and a few
big ones.
And at the final harvest,
which is probably about 12
weeks after planting,
you're starting to get a little
bit of skew at the low density
treatment,
but at the medium and high
density treatments,
you've got a lot of skew.
Okay?
Now this is something that was
going on, by the way,
in those trout experiments;
you were getting a few big ones
and a lot of little ones.
In the plants living in the
Dutch dunes, you were getting a
few big ones and a lot of little
ones.
It's a pretty widespread
pattern that happens as density
increases.
There's going to be
intra-specific competition.
Some individuals are going to
be better at it than others.
Okay?
And it's going to result in
these kinds of size and growth
distributions.
So the more competition there
is, the greater the skew will be
between lots of little ones and
a few big ones.
So that means that competition
is producing an asymmetry,
and this asymmetry,
where you have a really skewed
size distribution,
just basically means that a few
individuals are going to be
doing most of the surviving and
reproducing,
and a lot of individuals are
going to be doing most of the
dying,
and not reproducing.
In many cases the number of
large individuals is relatively
constant, while the number of
small individuals varies much
more widely.
That's the law of constant
final yield.
Okay?
Or the flat line that we saw
with the trout that were planted
at- were seeded into the
streams,
at many different densities,
but you always ended up with
roughly the same number.
That was probably the number of
the large surviving competitive
individuals, and the small
individuals are being squeezed
out.
That has an evolutionary
consequence.
This is a direct tie now
between population dynamics and
natural selection.
Not all those who are born will
survive to reproduce;
some are starving or are being
crowded out.
And not all who survive to
reproduce are large and in good
shape.
Many of them,
in fact, are in poor condition
and have few offspring.
So intra-specific competition
produces great variation in
capacity to reproduce and in
reproductive success,
and that means that wherever
you have reproductive and
mortality skew,
that's being produced by
intra-specific competition,
you are generating the
conditions for natural
selection.
It's as though there's an
internal process in ecology that
just hands you the conditions
for natural selection on a
dinner plate.
Now I previously mentioned the
case of the collapse of the
sardine fishery in California.
And the sardine fishery,
which collapsed in California
between about 1948 and 1955--
and still hasn't come back by
the way--
it collapsed because of
conditions that were affecting
juvenile sardines that were out
in the plankton in the Pacific.
It did not collapse because of
a fishery that was operating on
the adult sardines;
and this is pretty well
established now.
When fewer and fewer juveniles
were being recruited into the
adult population,
the individual adults were
essentially experiencing a
release from intra-specific
competition.
So their response was to grow
faster;
they could eat more,
they could grow faster and they
could make more babies.
And just as the last boats in
that fleet were pulling in and
deciding to stop fishing,
they were catching a very few,
very big sardines;
the sardines were about a meter
long.
They had gone from that big to
that big, and that was what the
release from intra-specific
competition had done to them.
And if they were able to
re-establish the fishery and
have lots of babies and have the
babies recruit into the
population properly,
and grow up,
the size would shrink right
back down.
That would be the impact of
density dependent population
growth on the California sardine
population.
Okay, populations are held in
check by lots of things.
They're not just held in check
by food.
They are held in check by
breeding sites,
by space, by lots of limiting
resources.
As populations increase in
density, the individuals shift
along reaction norms.
They reduce growth,
they are smaller;
when they become adults they
experience more variation in
adult size;
they have lower fecundity and
more variation in fecundity;
and they have higher mortality
and more variation in mortality,
as they encounter density
dependence.
Now if you have a successful
species--okay?
So it's a dominant species in
its local habitat,
in its ecosystem,
then intra-specific
competition,
where these kinds of things are
going on,
is often a more important brake
on its growth than
inter-specific competition.
And that's because,
because it's dominant,
it's numerically abundant,
and the average interaction
that an individual has is with
another individual of the same
species,
rather than with some
individual from another species.
So that would be a circumstance
under which we could expect that
intra-specific competition,
generating all of these
effects, is likely to be
important.
If the species are rare,
or if they're often at a low
population density,
then the opposite might be the
case;
then the interactions with
other species may be generating
these kinds of effects.
But whether the effects are
generated by interactions with
other individuals of your own
species,
or individuals of another
species, the impact of increased
overall density is likely to be
qualitatively similar.
It's going to produce reduced
growth, smaller adult size,
lower fecundity,
higher mortality,
and more variation in all of
these parameters.
Okay, next time we're going to
do competition between species.
But we have a few minutes this
morning,
because I managed to get
through this one a little more
quickly than usual,
and so I would be happy to take
questions on anything,
if you wanted to ask;
and we have about five minutes.
>
You know, a lack of questions
means that everything is just so
stunningly clear that everybody
could explain it perfectly well
themselves.
Fantastic.
I once had the experience,
when I was in my first year of
graduate school in British
Columbia, of being asked to be a
TA.
I had arrived in January,
and I was asked to be a TA in
Spring semester,
and I was a TA in a statistics
course.
And I stepped into this
statistics course and discovered
that even though the Fall
semester had been taught by one
of the greatest teachers at the
University of British Columbia,
a man who was revered for the
clarity of his lectures and for
the engagement of his speaking
style,
that the students,
in fact, knew very little
statistics.
And the problem was that they
had thought, because he was so
clear, that they understood
everything.
That was not the case.
They couldn't understand it
until they explained it
themselves, and they discovered
they couldn't explain it
themselves.
Any questions?
Have a good day.